foreign
brought in the voice actor for Ellie do
you think she got paid much or was this
opening scene a labor of love look if
the delivery of that pun had you
groaning buckle up because they don't
get any better after birth
here's a sin for anyone in Jester
otherwise who's ever made the yeah but
you've never experienced being kicked in
the ball's argument
[Music]
wow that was like the ideal birth I mean
minus the zombie attack getting bitten
the high risk of infection the ass
splinters and the thought of raising a
child in The Apocalypse of course but
man at least it was quick hey I remember
you you're the uh the uh the lady from
the place I know she's important because
his flashlights lingered on her for so
long who is she again damn it show would
have previously on if killed you
take her with you to Boston
find someone to bring her up
volunteering your child to be raised in
Boston
wrapping a baby up with a flick knife
you know sometimes life hits you with
senses you just never thought you'd have
to say
how long have we known each other
saying this as if it has any bearing on
the fact that this baby could be seconds
away from turning into a mushroom zombie
as if babies weren't annoying enough
already
saw Europe
now and then you kill me I don't know
Anna this feels pretty selfish
you've got a knife can't you do it
yourself you're asking your best friend
to live with the memory of killing her
best friend for the rest of her life
also knowing how important Ellie is to
Marlene it is insane that she trusts her
with Joel and Tess I mean it is a stroke
of ridiculous good luck the Joel ends up
being as solid as he does cover her ears
cover her ears cover her ears you're in
close space about to fire a gun when you
go to a shooting range you wear earplugs
and extra sound protection over them
you've got a newborn baby there with
developing ears take her outside or even
downstairs covering her ears won't do sh
also he does not
casting Ashley Johnson in this critical
role but only letting us have her for 9
minutes and 50 seconds Beefaroni Chef
Boyardee have you ever played this as if
the apocalypse wasn't Bleak enough Here
Comes Jolie to add tinned beef and
Boggle talk about bad luck military
drops bombs not one of them hits the
building you're trying to demolish yes
I'm sure that was the bad luck the
contractors were focusing on and not the
fact that the world was ending around
them along with their livelihoods
[Music]
kids also why are we worried about loud
noises anymore did that just stop being
a thing how does Joel know that this
place is free of cordyceps
you better come take a look at this
cliche it's a matter
in the game and I'm happy to see this
nod but how the have giraffes of
All Creatures survive 20 years into the
apocalypse also how exactly did she spot
them from the top of the ladder when
Joel gets to the top he doesn't see
anything and then chases her ass up
multiple flights of steps before seeing
what she sees Ellie being able to spot
the giraffes is about as realistic as
well the drafts being there in the first
place Joel and Ellie look upon the
family of giraffes as a Wonder of Nature
and a brief respite from the world of
violence and suffering instead of the
three meals a day and fashionably warm
clothing that they truly are is it
everything you hoped for got exception
down you can't deny that for you hey I
remember that that was the uh the uh the
thing they said at the place I know it's
important because of the deliberate
delivery damn it show would have
previously on have killed you after
always been through everything I've done
it can't be for nothing it can
cheap ranch
the moon will follow you anywhere you go
unless there's a particularly cool zoo
animal on the loose in which case I'm
ditching you quicker than you can say
Left Behind bye we finish what we
started which HBO means two seasons of
material stretched into five followed by
five and ounce spin-offs nobody asked
for only one of which will actually make
it to air before being canceled so what
was wrong with you it's for this the guy
who shot me missed hey I remember that
that was the uh the uh the thing they
said at the place the image show would
have previously on if what did a green
grape say to the purple grape review
idiot oh I've got one what do you call
an early morning surprise attack an AM
Bush
if you hadn't been so busy punting maybe
you'd have seen that one coming I had
five minutes only job was to protect me
I still almost got killed
how'd you do it a Nifty Little Thing
Called blot armor you see Joel has to
stay alive so they can be the hero of
the story and choose to sacrifice the
person he holds most deer for the
greater good right you would be one
person I never wanted to be in debt to
but I owe you I mean to be fair you only
have to give him a battery and some
supplies that was the original deal
right he chose to take Ellie further
than the original agreement our doctor
he thinks that the cordycepsinelli has
grown with her since birth he thinks it
could be a carriage hole he thinks it
could she's happy to sacrifice Ellie's
life on the unproven hypothesis of one
doctor I'm sure everyone's desperate for
a cure at this point but we're talking
about removing a child's brain based on
a maybe it produces a kind of chemical
messenger it makes normal cordyceps sync
the cheese quarter steps it's why she's
immune then why does she still get
attacked by them shouldn't they think
that she's one of them and ignore her if
not why aren't they attacking each other
and furthermore why do I keep trying to
find logic in a made-up cure for a
made-up infection also how long has Joel
been unconscious if the answer isn't
several weeks I want to know how
this doctors figured everything out so
quickly and with the level of confidence
that makes Ellie aside acceptable please
you don't understand I'm the only one
who understands attempting to have a
monopoly on guilt slash obligation slash
parenting slash the greater good or
whatever the it is these two are
using to justify their own brand of
murder walking out to the highway
leaving there with this pack considering
we're talking about a woman who is
lobotomizing the child of her best
friend this seems like an oddly
sentimental Choice letting Joel go might
be the right thing to do but why the
does she care about that she knows
his reputation kill him Joe will
contemplate his Escape for all of the
very long walk through the hospital
sometime while also somehow not being
nearly long enough to justify the
magnitude of what he's about to do he
said keep walking
thanks to the magic of Quick Cuts and
super fast editing this works
you don't have the bullets for this
either you've already shot the guy in
the leg and alerted the whole Hospital
what more was he going to do bleed on
you man this show really did capture a
lot of cool details from the game it
even included the mod that makes Joel
invulnerable to gunfire
[Music]
straight murder Joel tears through this
Hospital in a way that makes John Wick
look like Mr Rogers I feel like we're
supposed to admire Joel's determination
to save Ellie at whatever cost but it's
a rough watch when the people he's
determinating are just doing their jobs
and likely have no clue what's
happening to Ellie or why she's ready
Joe awakes from his concussion argues
with Marlene then the raid redemptions
his way through the hospital and manages
to arrive seconds before Ellie's surgery
is about to begin seconds this is insane
timing people doctors who and brown
could have teamed up and still not
pulled this off so perfectly how did you
get in here he said as if the answer
matters I won't let you take her
bringing a scalpel to a gunfight also
I'm sure killing that surgeon won't have
any consequences down the line or in
season two yep no further problems will
result from killing that doctor not even
one Laura Bailey plays a character that
should be healing but instead focuses on
doing damage cliche also teasing us with
Laura Bailey but without even a gesture
of 25 words of dialogue trusting any
elevator during the apocaly lips I
wouldn't enter an elevator until Society
had been rebuilt and even then I'd still
wait a decade or two and only if my
knees are really acting up so what would
she decide maybe you know the answer to
this if you bothered to ask before lying
and sedating her sure Joel's violating
Ellie's autonomy by making the decision
for her but you don't get to claim any
moral High Ground when you didn't ask
her either Marlene even after what
you've done we can still find a way the
bullet lodged in the brain of that
surgeon would likely take issue with
this claim Raiders attacked the hospital
I barely got you out of there lying and
not just lying but lying badly by adding
unnecessary layers to the LIE which
makes you look about as suspicious as a
50-something-year-old man driving away
from a hospital with a sedated teenager
in a flop sweat
you've just come after her Joel chooses
cold-blooded murder again and I just
missed the days of Pedro Pascal playing
a Charming Prince Space Cowboy or drug
dealer
driving driving
wasting valuable minutes of your finale
mint also the border between Wyoming and
Utah doesn't look like this it's mostly
flat but you would know that when you
film everything in Canada well
Sarah and I used to hike like this all
the time in Texas not a lot of mountains
to hike in Texas unless you made a lot
of trips from Austin over to Guadalupe
Mountains National Park even that's an
eight-hour drive are you gonna drive
eight hours to hike all the time I don't
think so anyway the point is driving in
Texas sucks more trolls sucks more
hiking sucks or whatever point I was
making I swear to me that everything you
said about the fireflies is true
I swear sure a man on a scale of one two
really guilty that loaded pause
ranks a solid puppy sitting next to a
pile of poop pointing at the goldfish
okay Ellie believes this or has been
Stockholm syndromed into believing it
either way I'm fascinated to see how
this turns out and I'm sure it won't be
neutered by something like a five-year
time Jump
there's one thing that never fails nice
glass of warm milk a little nap and a
total frontal lobotomy it's a veggie
Source let's finish thesaurus
hey you you're finally awake
what is that uh this would be a giraffe
Isaac Newton is it everything you hoped
for
Utah home of America's most powerful
weirdos moon rocks tastes better than
Earth rocks why
meteor that's not funny that's not funny
at all what surgery I'd like to take his
face off the are you doing keep
walking this must have register on an
emotional level
first distract Target
then block his blind jab count with
cross to left cheek
discombobulate swear to me that
everything you said about the fireflies
is true I swear
I don't believe you